you want to talk to some folk
i would love to bring in some company
i've been dying to get this dude on the
show uh one of the preeminent nba
insiders in america right now
yahoo forks chris haynes
also tnt
this man does it all he is the people's
nba insider senior nba insider from
yahoo sports chris what's good with you
man how are you
guys man thanks for having me on man and
i wish you guys nothing but success on
this new journey man this is big time
what y'all doing so i'm happy to be a
part of it
appreciate you thank you listen thank
you so much i want to start i want to
start you off with with how we started
the show the biggest story uh at least
in our world today
uh is is no charges being uh brought
against the officers involved
with uh brianna taylor's killing at
least no charges related to the death of
brianna taylor
i want to start there with you
a how do you feel but i'm gonna ask you
a double barrel question as we call it a
how do you feel in response to the news
but b
you've been in the bubble you've been
right there in the midst of this
movement of athlete activism that's
taken place in the nba's orlando bubble
how do you think they're going to
respond because they've been calling for
justice for brianna now that the system
once again said no
i i'm actually curious to see what the
next step is that the players are going
to take so how do you feel how do you
think the players feeling or how they're
going to react
meet me personally i'm numb right now um
obviously this is something that
i think a lot of us expected um i think
we were kind of given a hint i believe
it was the republican national
convention one of the conventions
recently where it kind of hinted at
an outcome like this um in today's
pressler and so um
you know it's sad it's definitely
unfortunate um
you know too often
this is something that we experience uh
two too too many times and you know in
our lifetime where
people of color
uh do not get the justice they deserve
and um
this is another one of those incidents
uh with that being said as it as it
relates to the players you know i i
expect you know one of the most
outspoken guys and i've been proud of
him for
speaking out he's a young brother you
know you guys know him all too well in
boston jaylen brown he's one of he's
been one outspoken brothers
here and trying to make sure we keep the
message of lie alive as it pertains to
to social justice and
racial discrimination racial profiling
you know he's been one of the fifth man
main
figures here
in this bubble and so he plays the night
uh they play the miami heat tonight so
it'd be interesting to see what he says
publicly because i'm pretty sure he will
speak about it but i think for for the
most part this was a verdict that
a lot of people sadly expected to happen
it's at this point like that uh you know
it's like
we've been here before and so now what
i'm hoping i'm hoping that we keep
uh you know there's been progress that
has been made over the last four or five
months you know for the first time in my
lifetime i can say that
i've seen some cops held accountable
probably not to the extent of that we
want but
definitely
to a greater extent than what we're used
to um doing this you know black lives
matter movement whatever you want to
call it but
i just hope that we we keep the foots on
the necks of these politicians judges
and the judicial system
to to make sure we continue to hold them
accountable hopefully we can do
something more
you know chris i want to ask you just to
follow up on that you know some of the
players
led by the milwaukee bucks initially uh
after what happened in kenosha said okay
we're not gonna play and then
uh the playoff games were were postponed
for a couple of days
and there was a sense that some people
didn't really want to play how about now
i mean we're in the western conference
in eastern conference finals
just based on the conversations that
you've had you get the sense that
players
are
committed to playing or is there still
some hesitancy about being in that
bubble when
all this is happening in the world
well there there was always hesitancy
about about playing um you know guys had
reservations before they even got to the
bubble uh feeling like if they played
entertainment if they provided
entertainment that it would drown out
the positive things that's going on in
society as it pertains to people of
course of color receiving justice um
with that being said you know that
milwaukee bucks uh boycott you know
they're the team that started and i give
them all props to it
this was something that was in there
right in their backyard so they felt
they needed to take a stand and uh but
it left all the other teams in a more of
a position at having to choose what do
they do moving forward so collectively
you know it ended up being a boycott and
so the
i'm not going to say concern but i think
what's going to be an issue moving
forward first of all i don't i don't see
a place stopping right now i don't see
that but if play were to stop the issue
that would come up is okay
what is it going to take
to re you know to to get back to playing
because that was kind of problem lebron
james had when the boycott happened
initially he was like okay the milwaukee
bucks you guys did this and it forced us
to sit because how are we going to take
the court after you guys are sitting now
what are we asking for now you know what
is our goal
to be able to rejoin the court what what
what are what are our demands and so
they they work some things out with the
league and got some initiatives approved
and owners are going to do more invest
more money into
things that's going to elevate the black
community so now
it's like if they stop playing
what's the next step you know are they
stop and play for good or they stop and
play and then like who what are you
asking like are you going back to the
owners to ask for something so that's
the kind of complexity uh about halton's
play again and that's why i don't see
that happening this time around
yeah
um so on the court you mentioned um
let's just do that we haven't talked
about celtics heat today celtics he play
game
uh four tonight
um
i said
when the heat were up 2-0
that even though we've seen teams come
back from an o2 deficit i don't see it
happening in this case
and then the celtics go and they do that
thing in game three and michael holland
is doing the praise victory dance
because oh now it's a series now i told
you i thought it's a serious about okay
got it how do you see these two
conference finals uh playing out uh from
this point forward
guys i i still think it has the
possibility of going to
i really do i think we look at the first
two fans miami won
you know it wasn't really any large
margins in either game and so
both teams are right there i think miami
heat they just made enough winning plays
down the stretch
to pull off those games and then we saw
what boston did in game three and so it
was it's one of the scenarios like if i
saw the
miami up 20
you know
two or three times throughout both of
those first two games then i would i
could i can
easily say that you know what i just
really feel like from top to bottom
miami are just better but the games that
are so close in all three games and even
though miami has pulled them up
it hasn't been easy you know like i said
it's been played out of stretch jimmy
butler in particular have made some you
know key plays on the offensive end and
defensive ends that's kind of helped
still don't steal both of those games
but um then you know bounds block as
well but you know i think it still has
potential to go the distance this is a
team
getting gordon hayward back and talking
about the selfie this is a team
who
super talented they're versatile they
can go with different lineups so i'm not
i'm not ruling them out at all uh you
know i i still would favor miami
just because what i've seen
yeah i would favor them
don't take what i'm saying to vegas and
put all your chips no i'm not saying
that i'm you know i'm not don't lose
your money now i'm just i'm favoring
them simply because they're up
chris who do you think the best player
in the series is this heat celtic series
who's the best player
it's tough guys look
gonna go with jimmy butler
i'm gonna go with jimmy butler just
because on both ends of the floor he's
one of the
you know top
five players maybe even higher than that
when you talk about players that can do
it on both ends
um but look you know if you look at
miami heat the way they've been winning
all throughout this postseason it hasn't
always been jimmy butler you know it's
been tyler hero goran's roger you know
bam and so they got a lot of guys who
who can you know put up buckets and make
timely shots when it matters most so i'm
gonna go with jimmy but look man you
can't dismiss
jason tatum out there you can't dismiss
jaylen brown you know what i mean like
it can be any it can be a number of
eight different players who can be the
best player
which depending on the game you know so
it's tough if i had to pick a pick a
player obviously i gotta pick up the
multi you know multi all-star jimmy
butler
well a lot of talk about uh him not
getting mvp but we know who the best
player in the world is that's still
lebron james until further notice his
lakers
up 2-1
but just like the eastern conference
finals could easily be 2-1 denver based
on you know the last couple of games are
the lakers in trouble
and if not
why not
because i believe they are
yeah i wouldn't say they're in trouble
mike
you know he's even even even last night
game you know that i was at
uh blake was wearing cruise control it
really like it and i would it was kind
of baffling to me because it's like you
want to get this different nuggets team
out the way you know i wrote about it it
was kind of the lead of my story i went
to different nuggets almost got the
lakers right where they want them you
know they're one block away from being
down three exactly
exactly
and then that's when they make they move
and so you cannot sleep
on this different team at all uh
i still think lakers obviously are the
driver's seat i think they're more
talented i think they're gonna be much
more aggressive in the next game uh but
you
know denver i they're resilient
hard-fought team you know it's funny
like when you're at the game you got the
lakers [ __ ] they're rowdy they're
talking trash they're pawning dwight
howard
marquis morris and i was sitting over
there by the denver bench
last night just quiet
right they they just go about their
business and they do it well and so you
know i'm not it's funny i remember with
paul george
i believe they were uh let me see it was
3-3 in the series clippers denver
and they asked paul george you know
how do you feel he was like well
no we i wanted some spots it was
something
he said he said we're in the driver's
seat that's what he said we're sitting
in the driver's seat i'm like hold on
hold on here y'all went up 3-1
denver just won two in a row there's no
whole quarter whatsoever but you got it
for the driver's seat you know i i
didn't understand that who knows where
they're going yeah yeah yeah but but in
this case i'm going to go i'm going you
know i'm going to go and say lakers in
the driver's seat yeah okay that's fair
listen
talking about
going about your business and just doing
your job well same can be said for you
my friend super super proud of the work
you're doing thank you for holding it
down like you are man can't can't thank
you enough for taking your time i know
you're busy you can be breaking stories
right now thanks for bringing it down
with us thank you mike and mike to
continue success man anytime y'all need
me hit me up
oh we will thank you don't worry i
appreciate you thank you we're going to
take you up on that